can I just touch on what you said about  the about the Russian roulette with the  pill see like I will only sleep with  someone without a condom unless like I'm  kind of with them and that's that's the  thing and I know they're not with  anything they've been checked yeah yeah  yeah okay but if I forget my pill like  say a one day two day I don't play  Russian Roulette I'll openly say to him  look I forgot my pill we need to wrap up  be careful because that's my response  yeah because I've also heard these  stories where girls  I'm sorry but nothing against women but  this to me sounds so [ __ ] [ __ ] oh  I'm swearing sorry this sounds so weird  in my head where girls lie to baby shop  yeah and they say their own  contraception I'm thinking what are you  doing it's happened to a lot of  Americans I just don't get it you're  literally playing with fire